[Musik]
nach der chaotischen ersten debatte mit
vielen unterbrechungen war die spannung
an diesem abend bei der zweiten debatte
national groß ob deutschland sich wieder
aufführen würde wie vor einigen wochen
und joe biden ins wort fallen würde
in den wichtigen swing states und in
landesweiten umfragen liegt dann hinter
dem herausforderer joe biden hatte an
diesem abend gut und gerne sich
zurücklehnen können und schauen die
arbeit machen lassen aber der ehemalige
vize dann ließ sich nicht bedrängen
stattdessen griff hat schon immer wieder
an die post die stumpfheit funktion der
mikros die extra eingeführt wurde wurde
insofern auch nur selten gebraucht okay
das cover es war eines der bestimmenden
themen an diesem abend bei der debatte
präsident trump wiederholte noch einmal
was er schon vor wochen sagte das virus
wird verschwinden kann oder will sagte
immun
außerdem stellte er einen impfstoff
innerhalb von nur ein paar wochen in
aussicht ohne genau details zu nennen wo
er werke von ernst wurde
bitte liebe aber die realität für uns
sehen die amerikaner sieht immer noch
düster und trostlos aus mehr als 220
todesopfer und millionen arbeitslose
eine wirtschaft die immer noch nicht
richtig in gang gekommen ist und das
sehr reale risiko dass du draußen
weiterhin ein
unsichtbares virus über das land hinweg
fegt ich will noch einmal klarstellen
sagte joe biden das unter mir als
präsident sich kein land in die wahlen
einmischen wird das war
man vergisst das ja doch schnell bei den
vielen störgeräuschen und dem geraune um
und vor und auch nach der debatte sich
noch einmal in erinnerung zu rufen dass
russland nach 2016 auch jetzt wieder
versucht das wahlergebnis zu
manipulieren ich sehe keine roten und
keine blauen starten sagte joe biden
anlehnung an die parteifarben der
republikaner und demokraten
ich werde nicht demokratischer präsident
sein
ich werde amerikanischer präsident sein
der seine alte redewendung von barack
obama die ihn einst berühmt gemacht hat
aber das macht ja nichts
was er damit sagen wollte ich werde ich
mich um die einigkeit im land bemühen
versuchen die ideologischen gräben zu
schließen wenn ich im amt bin jump
überzeugendsten momente waren die in
denen er verfolgte was er sich offen
sich für den abend vorgenommen hatte
biden als politiker darzustellen
der in mehr als 40 jahren nicht das
erreicht hatte was er hätte erreichen
wollen oder sollen
warum hast du das nicht in acht jahren
unter barack obama gemacht und willst
dass erst jetzt angehen fragt der beiden
wieder und wieder
vor allem aber als es um die
strafrechtsreform und die politik
trotzdem ist der trans dass niemand
außer vielleicht anderen lincoln mehr
für afrika getan hätte eine sehr gewagte
these für einen mann dem es immer noch
schwer zu fallen scheint white supremacy
gruppen zu verurteilen
celebrity century break
was ihm auffällt und wichtig gewesen
wäre
statt beiden ständig für die
geschäftsgebaren seines sohnes hunter
verantwortlich zu machen
hier ist vice president of the united
states or in which eine vision zu
artikulieren die für weitere vier jahre
nicht nur seine wähler sondern das ganze
land ansprechen hätte können nachdem
trump bei der ersten debatte joe biden
wieder und wieder ins wort gefallen war
stellte sich auch die frage wie die
moderatoren an diesem abend die
situation hand haben würde
moderatorin küsten worker von nbc news
macht es ganz geschickt immer wieder
nahmen sich donald trump vor und fertigt
die mit einem einfachen danke
ministerpräsident wir müssen weiter ab
und stellte selbst den präsidenten
beeindruckt der sie innerhalb der
debatte an einer stelle sogar lobte die
eine frage die noch offen bleibt wer ist
sieger der ganzen veranstaltung heute
abend es ist schwer zu sagen
donald trump hätte eigentlich punkten
müssen vielleicht hätte er nicht nur
seinen herausforderer joe biden
angreifen müssen sondern sich souverän
hinstellen können und als amtsinhaber
sagen wie ihr das land auch in weiteren
vier jahren führen will
joe biden hat es sehr geschickt gemacht
er hat sich nicht von donald trump
editieren lassen hat seine vision
dargelegt er hat in die kamera guckt und
das land adressiert und damit gleich
auch noch mal betont wie er als
möglicher präsident nach donald trump
auftreten würde
vereint über ideologien hinweg sehen als
präsident für alle amerikaner